สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
ครูฟ้าคะวันนี้เรามาเจอกันวันอะไรคะวัน
นี้วันพุธค่ะครูเรียมวันพุธวัน
พุธวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 19
ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะเดือน
ตุลาคมปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 แล้วปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะโอเคตอน
นี้กี่โมงแล้วคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา 14
น 23 นาทค่ะ
[เพลง]
1423 นาที
โอเคเป็นยังไงบ้าง 14:00 นแล้วครูเรียม
กินข้าวหรือยัง
เรียมไม่กินข้าวค่ะครูเรียมไม่กินข้าว
แล้วูเรียมกินอะไรไม่กินหรอเรียมก็ดื่ม
น้ำดื่มน้ำแล้วก็กินขนม
อืเดี๋ยวเอาขนมให้ดู
ขนมขนมเค้
คุกกี้
ขนมใช่กินขนมูฟ้าเหรอคะคุณูฟ้ากินข้าว
หรือยังครูฟ้ากินข้าวแล้วค่ะครูฟ้าเพิ่ง
กินข้าวเสร็จใช่มเพราะครูฟ้ากินๆๆๆกิน
เสร็จครูฟ้าก็มาซูมนี่แหละมาสอนกับครู
เรียมนะคะครูฟ้ากินส้มตำค่ะนักเรียนลาบ
ส้มตำอืกินเยอะมากเลยใช่มคือครูฟ้ากิน
เยอะแล้วง่วงนอนมั้ยเนี่ยครูเรียมูฟ้า
ง่วงนอนมากเลยค่ะรู้สึกว่าูต้องไปนอนแล้ว
ล่ะเพะว่ากินเสร็จกินอิ่มก็ต้องนอนใช่มย
ใช่ๆกินอิ่มก็ต้องนอนธรรมดาถ้าเกิดครูฟ้า
นอนตอน 14:00 นครูฟ้านอนแล้วฝันมั้ย
โหปกติเราจะฝันใช่มั้ยคะครูเรียมถ้าเรา
นอนฝันบางคนก็ฝันบางคนก็ไม่ฝัน
นอครูฟ้าเนี่ยถ้านอน
ตอน 14:00 นเนี่ยครูฟ้าจะนอนแล้ว
ก็ฝันนะคะบางทีก็ฝันอืมนอนแล้วก็ฝันฝัน
ว่าได้กิน KFC ฝันว่าได้เล่นเกมฝันว่าได้
ไปสวิตเซอร์แลนด์ใช่มยฝันว่าถูก
ล็อตเตอรรี่
โหครูฟ้าฝันดีนะูฝันดีเหรอเออฝันดีใช่ๆ
ครูฝันดีนะคะเพราะว่าครูฟฝันว่าถูก
ลอตเตอรี่ก็ได้เงินใช่มยหรือฝันว่าได้ไป
สวิตเซอร์แลนด์ครูฟ้าอยากไป
สวิตเซอร์แลนด์นะคะแล้วก็บอกว่าครูฟ้า
เนี่ยฝันดีฝันแล้วก็ยิ้มแฮปปี้ใช่ไหมครู
เรียมล่ะครูเรียมฝันดีมใช่เรียมก็คิดว่า
ก็มีนะคะฝันดี
อืฝันดีแต่ว่าบางครั้งก็ฝันไม่ดีอ้าวฝัน
ไม่ดีฝันดีด้วยแล้วก็ฝันไม่ดีด้วยใช่มั้ย
คะใช่ค่ะฝันดีก็แบบเหมือนครูฟ้าฝันว่าได้
ไปเที่ยวอือืมแล้วก็ฝันแบบฝันแบบได้กิน
สิ่งที่ชอบกินอออืๆอันนี้ฝันดีใช่ส่วน
ใหญ่นับ
ประมาณ 90% ฝันดี
โอโก็ดีสิเพราะฝันดีแล้วก็จะยิ้มใช่มั้ย
คะ 90% เลยนะใช่ค่ะแต่ว่ายังมีอีก
10%  10% ที่เป็น
ฝันฝัน
ร้ายฝันร้ายนะคะนักเรียนฝันดีใชใช่ๆฝัน
ร้ายก็ไม่ร้องไห้ใช่มั้ยฝันร้ายใช่ๆฝัน
ร้ายก็จะร้องไห้
อือย่างงี้ครูเรียมบอกว่าครูเรียมเนี่ย
ฝันดี 90% แปลว่าครูเรียมก็ต้องเคยฝัน
ร้ายใช่มั้ยคะใช่ค่ะเคยฝัน
ร้ายส่วนมากนะเรียมจะฝันฝันร้ายตอนที่แบบ
ไม่สบาย
โอตอนที่ครูเรียมไม่สบายแล้วนอนก็จะนอน
ฝันร้ายหรอคะใช่ค่ะ
ใช่ฝันอะไรเรียมเคยฝัน
ว่าฝันว่าแบบเรียมอ่ะตายครูเรียมฝันว่า
ครูเรียม
ตายใช่ยังไงครูเรียมเล่าให้ฟังได้ไก็คือ
เรียมไม่รู้ว่าเป็นเพราะอะไรที่เรียมตายอ
อืแต่ในฝันนะในตอนที่เรียมฝันเนี่ยก็จะ
เห็นพ่อแม่
พี่ครอบครัวทุกๆคนอืมาที่บ้าน
อืใช่แล้วก็มีร่างกายของเรียมเนี่ยอยู่ใน
โลงศพโรงศพหรอคะครูเรียม
ใช่
นอนอยู่ในนี้เวลาตายใช่มยเราก็ต้องอยู่ใน
โรงศพอืใช่อยู่ในโรงศพเรียมเห็นเห็นทุกๆ
คนอืๆเรียมพูดพูดกับทุกๆคน
อืทุกๆคนไม่ได้
ยินไม่ได้ยินครูเรียมใช่
ออครูเรียมก็เลยแล้วก็มอง
มองไม่เห็น
เรียม
อืมองไม่เห็นโอ้โหุเรียมก็เข้าใจใช่ไหมม
ว่าเราตาย
แล้วใช่แล้วเรียมก็เลยแบบ
เรียกพี่สาวเรียกแม่พ่อแต่แบบไม่มีใครมอง
เห็นน่ากลัวมั้ยคะครูเรียมกลัวมไม่มีใคร
ได้ยินแบบเสียใจมากร้องไเสียใจใช่มออแล้ว
ก็ร้องไห้อืใช่ถ้าเกิดเราตายแล้วแม่ก็ไม่
เห็นเราพ่อไม่เห็นเราเพื่อนๆไม่เห็นเรา
มันก็เสียใจใช่มั้ยคะอืใช่ๆก็เลยแบบคิด
ว่าเป็นฝันร้าย
อือืเวลาตื่นขึ้นมาก็จะแบบรอร้องไห้อืๆๆๆ
ใช่ฝันร้ายไงฝันร้ายเนี่ยส่วนใหญ่จะร้อง
ไห้ใช่มั้ยคะร้องไห้ร้องไห้มากๆอืใช่แล้ว
ครูฟ้าล่ะคะครูฟ้าเคยฝัน
ร้ายแบบไหนบ้างเอ่อครูพ่อเคยฝันร้ายตอน
เด็กๆค่ะครูเหี่ยมคิดว่าตอนที่ครูพ่อฝัน
ร้ายครั้งแรกเนี่ยครูจำไม่ได้ว่าอายุเท่า
ไหร่นะูไม่ชัวร์นะคะแต่เคยเล่าเรื่องนี้
ไปแล้วว่าเพฝันร้ายนะคะคิดว่าน่าจะอายุ
ประมาณ
12  12 เออน่าจะน่าจะอายุประมาณ 12 นะคะ
อ 12 หรือว่า 10 ขวบหรือว่า 12 ขวบจำไม่
ได้และคไม่ชัวร์โหครูฟ้าก็จำได้จนถึงตอน
นี้ใช่ค่ะเพราะว่ามันเป็นฝันร้ายสำหรับ
ครูฟ้ามันเป็นฝันร้ายมากๆเลยนะคะคือครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยฝันว่าูฟ้าก็อยู่ที่บ้านใช่มย
อยู่ที่บ้านนะคะแล้วก็คิดว่าน่าจะต้อง
แชร์สกรีนครูพ้าขอแชร์สกรีนนะคะครูออได้
เลยค่ะ
ได้โอเคได้ต้องวาดรูปนิดหน่อยนะคะโอเค
แป๊บนึงนะคะครูฟ้าเนี่ยก็แชร์ไวบอร์ดขอ
แชร์ไวบอร์ด
ก่อนว่านเดี๋ยวนักเรียนน่าจะต้องดูรูปภาพ
เอาเนาะ
โอเคอันนี้เนี่ยบ้านครูฟ้านะคะแล้วก็บ้าน
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยมี 2 ชั้นอืในฝันเนี่ยครูฟ้าฝ
ตอนนั้นเนี่ยครูฟ้าเนี่ยก็นอนนะนอนน่าจะ
เป็นเวลา
ประมาณ
5 ไม่รู้อ่ะไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ 23:00 นก็นอน
ปกติแหละตอนนั้นครูฟ้าน่าจะนอนเร็วแหละ
ครูฟ้าน่าจะนอนซัก
ประมาณ 21:00 นมั้งคะ
[เพลง]
อืมอือื 21:00 นและครูฟ้าเนี่ยอายุ 12
น่าจะ
12 ก็นอนเร็วใช่มั้ยนอนประมาณ 21:00 นนะ
คะทุกวันนี้นอน 3:00 นยังไม่นอนเลยนะคะ
แต่ตอนเด็กๆเนี่ยนอนเร็วเออก็นอนปกติแล้ว
ครูฟ้าก็ฝันว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยตื่นขึ้นมาใช่ม
เดี๋ยววาดตัวเองอันนี้ครูฟ้านะคะนอนอยู่
แล้วครูฟ้าก็ฝัน
ฝันนะคะฝันฝันว่าครูฟ้าตื่นขึ้นมาแล้วครู
ฟ้าก็ตื่นขึ้นมาจากที่นอนเลยนะก็ลุกขึ้น
มาแล้วก็นั่งใช่มยลุกขึ้นมานะฮะแบบครูฟ้า
เนี่ยลุกขึ้นมาอันนี้เตียง
นอนแล้วก็เป็นนายฝันนะคะนักเรียนเผื่อน
เดี๋ยวนักเรียนงงนะครูฟ้ากลัวว่าครูฟ้า
พูดงงอันนี้นายฝันอืมในฝันตื่นขึ้นมาใน
ฝันคูฟ้าตื่นขึ้นมานั่งแล้วูฟ้าก็หาคุณ
แม่คุณแม่อยู่ที่ไหนก็เดินแล้วก็เดินใน
บ้านใช่มยเดินเดินเดินๆๆๆๆนะคะแม่อยู่ไหน
ฟ้าก็หา
แม่ฟ้าหาคุณแม่ไม่เจอคุณแม่ไม่อยู่ในบ้าน
อืเอ้าชั้นชั้นที่ 2 ฟ้าก็หาคุณแม่อยู่
ไหนไม่เจอ้าก็เดินลงมาชั้นที่
1 ก็หาคุณแม่ไม่เจอนะคะคุณแม่อยู่ที่ไหน
แล้วครูฟ้าก็เลยเดินออกมาจากบ้านเดี๋ยวขอ
เคลียร์แป๊บนึงนะอันเนี้ยบ้านครูฟ้ามันจะ
สมมุติว่าถ้าอันนี้เป็นประตูบ้านใช่
ไหมตรงนี้ก็จะเป็นระเบียงนิดนึงนะ
คะแล้วตรงนี้ก็จะเป็นบันได
อืเล็กๆอืและตรงนี้ก็จะเป็นประตูรั้วค่ะ
นัก
เรียนประตูรั้วบ้านจะต้องมีประตูรั้วเนาะ
ของคนไทยนะคะของนักเรียนูฟัวไม่รู้ว่ามี
มั้ยแต่ตรงเเป็นประตูรั้วครูฟ้าก็ยืนอยู่
ตรงนี้แล้วครูฟ้าก็แม่แม่อยู่ที่ไหนแม่
แม่อยู่ไหนใช่มเออเรียกแม่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยก็
เดินๆๆๆมาตรงนี้แล้วแล้วก็เห็นคุณ
แม่คุณแม่ทำอะไรคะคุณแม่ยืนอยู่นอกบ้านออ
ครูฟ้านะคะอันนี้ครูฟ้าครูฟ้าอยู่ข้างใน
บ้านคุณแม่อยู่ข้างนอกบ้านใช่มยอือืม
เพราะว่าอันนี้เนี่ยคือประตูรั้วนะคะนัก
เรียนเนี่ยประตูรั้วประตูรั้วนะคะคุณแม่
เนี่ยอยู่ข้างนอกบ้านแล้วก็ครูฟังได้เห็น
คุณแม่คุณแม่เนี่ยร้องไห้ค่ะคูเรียมอ้า
คุณแม่ร้องไห้อยู่นอกบ้านถูกต้องค่ะคุณ
แม่บอกว่า
ฟ้าฟ้ามาหา
แม่อือแม่คุณแม่บอกให้ครูฟ้าเนี่ยเดินออก
มาหาคุณแม่นะคะครูฟ้าก็ร้องไห้เพราะว่า
ครูฟ้าเห็นคุณแม่ใช่มั้ยครูฟ้าก็ร้องไห้
ครูฟ้าก็คิดครูฟ้าจะเดินออกมาหาคุณแม่แต่
มันมีผู้หญิงคนนึงค่ะครูเรียมครูฟ้าเนี่ย
กำลังจะเดินมาหาคุณแม่ใช่มยแต่มีผู้หญิง
คน
นึงครูฟ้าไม่รู้ผู้หญิงคนนี้เป็นใครนะคะ
แต่ครูฟ้าจำได้เดี๋ยวครูฟ้าซูมนะแป๊บนึง
นะคะผู้หญิงอยู่ในบ้านครูฟ้าหรอผู้หญิง
ใช่ค่ะอยู่ในบ้านอันนี้คือซูมออกมาแล้วนะ
คะ
ซูมผู้หญิงคนนี้เนี่ย
ผมสั้น
อ้าผมหยิกนะคะนี่ผมหยิกเป็นอย่างนี้ค่ะ
นักเรียนเนี่ยหยิกๆๆๆผมสีอะไรคะสีขาวหมด
เลย
ค่ะและใส่ชุดเสื้อ
ผ้าสีดำ
อืแบบนี้เลยใ้อสีดำใช่โหอันนี้เป็น
กระโปรงนะคะนัก
เรียนครูฟ้าเนี่ยจำหน้าไม่ได้ครูฟ้าจำได้
ว่าผมสีขาวเสื้อสีดำอืกระโปรงสีดำเป็นชุด
ไทยค่ะชุดไทยแบบอผู้หญิงคนนี้น่าจะอายุ
80 อืมครูฟ้าคิดนะคิดว่านะคะคิดว่าน่าจะ
อายุ 80 แล้วผู้หญิงคนนี้เนี่ยก็เดินมาหา
ครูฟ้านี่มาหาครูฟ้านะคะและก็บอกครูฟ้า
ว่าไม่ให้ออกไปหาคุณ
แม่
ออครูฟ้าก็ร้องไห้นะคะครูฟ้าก็ร้องไห้ครู
ฟ้าบอกว่าครูฟ้าอยากไปหาแม่แม่อยู่ข้าง
นอกบ้านอืแม่เรียกครูฟ้าใช่มผู้หญิงคนนี้
ก็บอกว่าไม่
ได้ห้ามครูฟ้าออกไปหาคุณแม่ไม่ได้ไม่ให้พ
บอกครูฟ้าอยากออกไปครูฟ้าก็เรียกหาแม่ๆ
คุณแม่ก็ร้องไห้นะคะคุณแม่เนี่ยก็ร้องไห้
ร้องไห้แล้วก็บอกฟ้าครูฟ้าก็ร้องไห้ใช่
ค่ะแม่บอกฟ้ามาหาแม่เร็วครูฟ้าก็บอกว่า
ครูฟ้าอยากไปหาแม่แต่ผู้หญิงคนนี้เนี่ย
ไม่ให้แล้วผู้หญิงคนนี้เนี่ยนะคะผู้หญิง
คนนี้เนี่ยก็บอกคุณแม่ว่าไปจะไปไหนก็ไปไป
เลยไม่ให้เข้ามาในบ้านไล่แมู่ฟ้าใช่ค่ะ
ไล่คุณแม่ครูฟ้านะคะไล่คุณแม่ครูฟ้าและก็
ไม่ให้ครูฟ้าออกไปไม่ให้คุณแม่เข้ามาใน
บ้านไม่ให้ครูฟ้าออกไปนอก
บ้านสักพักนึงคุณแม่เนี่ยเอ่อคุณแม่เนี่ย
ตอนแรกร้องไห้ใช่มยแล้วคุณแม่ก็เปลี่ยน
ค่ะเปลี่ยนเป็น
โกรธคุณแม่ก็พูดกับครูฟ้าว่าออกมาแม่บอก
ให้ออก
มาแม่ก็โกรธมากนะคะแบบแบบ
ว่าโกรธโกรธโกรธมากออคน
ลุกใช่ค่ะคูณฟ้าร้องไห้หนักมากแล้วคุณแม่
ก็โกรธมากๆแล้วก็บอกว่าออกมาแล้วก็พูดไม่
ดีเยอะๆเลยค่ะบอกบอกให้ออกมาจะออกมามยนะ
คะครูฟ้าก็ร้องไห้แล้วครูฟ้าก็ตอนแรกครู
ฟ้าร้องไห้เพราะว่าครูฟ้าอยากไปหาคุณแม่
แต่พอคุณแม่โกรธครูฟ้าก็กลัวแล้วครูฟ้าก็
ร้องไห้เพราะว่ากลัวผู้หญิงคนนี้ก็บอกว่า
ครูฟ้าออกไปไม่
ได้ห้ามออกไปหาแม่แล้วผู้หญิงคนนี้ก็เลย
ไล่คุณแม่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยบอกไป
ๆ
แล้วแล้วเกิดอะไรขึ้นครูฟ้าก็ตื่น
ค่ะเพราะว่าจริงๆแล้วครูฟ้านอนอยู่ที่นี่
ใช่มั้ยนอนอยู่ตรงนี้นะคะนี่ครูฟ้าก็
นอนแล้วก็คุณเอ่อครูฟ้าเนี่ยนอนแล้วครู
ฟ้าก็ก็ร้อง
ไห้นอนร้องไห้นะคะคุณแม่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยเห็น
อืมคุณแม่เห็นคุณแม่ก็เลยฟ้าร้องไห้เป็น
อะไรคุณแม่ก็มาปลุกครูฟ้าครูฟ้าก็เลยตื่น
อืนั่นแหละแล้วคุณแม่ก็เห็นครูฟ้าเนี่ย
นอนร้องไห้แล้วก็พูดแม่ๆอะไรอย่างเงี้ย
อ๋อใช่คุณแม่ได้มาปลุกครูฟ้ามั้ยบอกว่า
ใช่ค่ะคุณแม่มาเรียกแม่บอกฟ้าตื่นฟ้าเป็น
อะไรฟ้าก็เลยตื่นขึ้นมานะคะก็เลยไม่รู้
ว่าสรุปแล้วคุณแม่เข้ามาบ้านมั้ยแล้วครู
ฟ้าออกไปหรือเปล่าูฟ้าไม่รู้ไงอืแต่ว่า
แบบครูฟ้าก็ตื่นก็แบบแล้วก็ตื่นขึ้นมาแค่
นั้นก็คือฝันจบแค่นั้นแค่นั้นจบอันนี้จบ
สตอรี่ฝันแต่มันเป็นฝันที่ครูฟ้าจำได้
แม่นมากเลยนะคะว่าจำได้แบบ 4dx เลยอ่ะจำ
จำอะไรหายอย่างได้ตั้งแต่อายุ 12 ขวบเนาะ
จนถึงตอน
นี้ใช่ค่ะจำรายโหผ่านมานานมากอืมเพราะครู
ฟ้าร้องไห้มากๆใช่มยแล้วก็กลัวด้วยค่ะใน
ฝันมันน่ากลัวนะคะแบบว่าใช่เออมันมันแบบ
บ้านก็มืดๆมองไม่ค่อยเห็นอย่างเงี้ย
อืก็เลยอันนี้คือฝันร้ายค่ะนักเรียนพว่า
ร้องไห้อยากไปหาคุณแม่บอกเป็นฝันร้ายของ
ครูฟ้าอือืโอเคแล้ว
แบบความจริงเนี่ยครูฟ้าบอกว่ามีฝันร้าย
อยู่ประมาณ 3 ครั้งใช่มั้ยใช่อันนี้คือ
ครั้งที่ 1 อ๋อครั้งที่ 1 เมก็แบบเล่าไป
แล้ว 1
ครั้งใช่แต่คิดว่าแบบมีฝันมีฝันร้ายอีกนะ
ออมีอีกใช่มยเื่อนักเรียนทุกคนมีฝันร้าย
อีกนะคะใช่อยากฟังมั้ยอยากฟังเดี๋ยวเรียม
ดูเวลาก่อนหมดแล้วชอบลืมชอบลืมเวลา 2  3
อยากแต่ไม่ทันอ้าจะเหลืออีก 1 นาทีเหรอ
เหลืออีก 1 นาทีค่ะครูเรียม
อ้าเวลาก็จะหมดแล้วเพิ่งเล่าได้เรื่อง
เดียวเองได้เรื่องเดียวอืใช่อืยังเหลือ
อีกเห็นมใช่แต่ว่านักเรียนก็รู้แล้วแหละ
ว่าอันนี้คือฝันอฝันร้ายใช่ฝันร้ายนัก
เรียนล่ะคะนักเรียนเคยฝันร้ายมแล้วนัก
เรียนจำได้มยว่าฝันว่าอะไรอืฝันว่าอะไรอ
จำสอได้หรือเปล่าใช่ใช่ก็ลองพูดออกมาเป็น
ภาษาไทยหรือว่าจะคอมเมนต์ข้างล่างวีดีโอ
นี้ก็ได้ใช่ค่ะใช่แล้วส่วนวันนี้เนี่ยหมด
เวลาแล้วเนาะคิดว่าหมดเวลาแล้วนะคะก็ใช่
แล้วค่ะอืเจอกันใหม่วดีโอหน้านะใช่แล้ว
ค่ะวันนี้ต้องลาไปก่อนค่ะครูฟ้าได้ค่ะครู
เรียมขอบคุณมากค่ะครูเรียมสสวัสดีค่ะบ๊าย
บาย